[Música]
el senado estadounidense aprobó un
modesto paquete de medidas contra el
control de armas justo después de que la
corte suprema de justicia- ampliará el
derecho a portar las fuera del hogar y
en defensa propia
ucrania y moldavia ya son oficialmente
candidatos para ingresar a la unión
europea así lo aprobaron por unanimidad
los líderes del bloque pero para entrar
al grupo europeo tendrán que adoptar una
serie de reformas les explicamos en
minutos
indígenas de ecuatorianos siguen
pidiendo la renuncia del presidente
guillermo olaso a pesar de que el
mandatario ha hecho algunas concesiones
durante la última jornada de protestas
los manifestantes intentaron entrar a la
asamblea nacional y terminaron en
choques con la policía
ampliamos desde quito
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda a tres
meses a muñoz
empezamos en eeuu porque el senado
aprobó un proyecto de ley para controlar
el porte de armas rompiendo tres décadas
de inacción al respecto la medida
restringiría aún más la verificación de
antecedentes de los posibles compradores
sin embargo los republicanos se negaron
a comprometerse con normativas más
radicales como la prohibición de rifles
de asalto o cargadores de alta capacidad
el proyecto se aprobó el mismo día en
que la corte suprema de justicia
ratificó el derecho a portar armas fuera
del hogar y en defensa propia al anular
una ley que data de hace 100 años y que
lo prohibía en el estado de nueva york
el presidente joe biden se declaró
decepcionado puesto que la normativa
sigue una serie de tiroteos que han
dejado decenas de muertos en el país ex
un golpe para los defensores del control
de armas el tribunal supremo de eeuu
anuló una ley que prohibía el porte de
armas en público en el estado de nueva
york ampliando así el derecho de los
estadounidenses a salir armados de sus
casas la asociación nacional de rifle el
poderoso lobby de armas celebró la
decisión victoria de la asociación
nacional del rifle el tribunal supremo
afirmó que el derecho a portar armas no
se detiene en la puerta de la casa de
una persona mientras que el plan
democrático no tardó en reaccionar
condenado firmemente el fallo
entiende todo el mundo lo que significa
un arma oculta
significa que no tienen ninguna
previsión de que alguien puede esconder
un arma y entrar en nuestro metro en
nuestras tiendas como las de búfalo
donde yo vivo la asociación nacional del
rifle defiende una lectura literal de la
segunda enmienda de la constitución de
eeuu que establece el derecho del pueblo
a portar armas en
1939 el tribunal supremo limitó esta
legislación a las fuerzas del orden pero
cambió su posición en 2008 cuando
estableció el derecho a postear un arma
en el hogar
sin embargo dejó en manos de los estados
la regulación del porte fuera de casa la
sentencia de este jueves pone fin a esta
flexibilidad y fija en piedra el derecho
a portar armas
estoy decepcionado con la decisión de la
corte suprema- hay un poco de consuelo y
la minoría que no compone la opinión de
la mayoría ha expuesto que no afecta a
todos los estados afecta sólo a 40
estados
la decisión tomada por una mayoría de
seis de los nueve jueces todos
conservadores se produce cuando el país
sigue conmocionado por una serie de
tiroteos incluido uno el 24 de mayo que
dejó 19 niños de primaria y dos
profesoras muertos en una escuela
primaria de texas
en otras noticias de eeuu ex
funcionarios del departamento de
justicia testificaron este jueves en una
nueva audiencia sobre el asalto al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 y
detallaron las maniobras del ex
presidente de donald trump para tratar
de invalidar la elección de joe baile en
esta quinta cita se centró en la presión
que ejerció el ex mandatario en la
justicia según las declaraciones strong
había pedido a funcionarios que se
limitarán a decir que los comicios
habían sido corruptos y que él se
encargaría del resto junto con los
congresistas republicanos
nos vamos al viejo continente el consejo
europeo aprobó a ucrania moldavia como
candidatas para ingresar a la unión
europea ahora esas naciones trabajarán
para obtener la membresía es una tarea
que podría tardar años pero constituye
un paso importante en lo que los 27
calificaron como un mensaje directo a
rusia
abriendo la puerta al futuro de ucrania
en la unión europea los niveles del
bloque concedieron al país estatus de
candidato en bruselas decisión que fue
celebrada por el presidente vladimir
selenski
acabamos de recibir la candidatura esta
es nuestra victoria chocado esto a sí
mismo
la hemos esperado durante 120 días y
durante 30 años venceremos al enemigo y
descansaremos y probablemente primero
reconstruiremos ucrania y luego
descansaremos
la medida fue aclamada como histórica
por los líderes de la unión europea que
también aceptaron la solicitud de
moldavia mientras a georgia otro estado
ex soviético se le dijo que obtendría el
estatus una vez que cumpliera con más
condiciones típicamente estoy convencida
que la decisión de hoy nos fortalece a
todos ucrania moldavia georgia y la
unión europea unidos frente a la amenaza
externa en
sitio interactivo estamos ofreciendo
ucrania moldavia y georgia una
perspectiva europea es una señal muy
fuerte con respecto a rusia y en el
contexto geopolítico que mencionamos
hicieron contención política menos
difusión hemos tomado la decisión de
otorgar a ucrania y moldavia un estatus
de candidato para unirse a la unión
europea a niño hotel ucrania solicitó la
membresía días después de que rusia
invadiera su territorio albania que
también ha sido candidato oficial
durante ocho años ha advertido a kiev
contra cualquier esperanza en un proceso
rápido
macedonia del norte es candidata desde
hace 17 años si no he perdido la cuenta
albania desde los 8
así que bienvenido ucrania es bueno
otorgarle el estatus de candidato pero
espero que el pueblo ucraniano no se
haga muchas ilusiones al respecto no
eximen y muchos otros cuatro países de
los balcanes occidentales están
profundamente frustrados por el
estancamiento de sus intentos de unirse
a la unión europea y tres de ellos
amenazaron con boicotear la reunión como
símbolo de protesta la pertenencia al
bloque viene con una larga lista de
condiciones para ucrania significará
llevar a cabo reformas judiciales y
comerciales y erradicar la corrupción el
proceso podría llevar alrededor de una
década y este jueves se presentaron
nuevos disturbios en las calles de la
capital de ecuador durante la undécima
jornada de protestas miles de
integrantes del movimiento indígena
intentaron ingresar al congreso pero la
policía los dispersó con bombas de gas
lacrimógeno lo que derivó en
enfrentamientos con los uniformados
cambiamos esta noticia desde quitó con
nuestro corresponsal gustavo ortega
gustavo cuéntenos cómo transcurrió la
última jornada
si la jornada ha transcurrido con
desplazamientos de los movimientos
indígenas desde la universidad central
hasta el ágora de la casa de la cultura
luego que el presidente de la república
se diera una de las demandas de los
movimientos indígena es por ello que ya
los grupos indígenas se encuentran en la
casa de la cultura pero también se
produjeron enfrentamientos en la
asamblea nacional cuando los movimientos
indígenas un sector de los movimientos
indígenas ha intentado tomar el
parlamento ecuatoriano esto ha resultado
con el fallecimiento de una persona
lleva a tres personas fallecidas a causa
de los movimientos indígenas en las
partes tres que ya se extienden por más
de una semana en este país pero también
se han producido
caravanas a diario se producen en
caravanas de la ciudadanía que ya
expresa su opinión un poco de cansancio
en el ecuador en contra de las
paralizaciones y de igual forma ha
sonado el día las campanas por parte de
la conferencia episcopal un gesto para
llamar a la paz y al diálogo de los
distintos sectores para que se sienten a
dialogar en este país
cuéntanos por qué el líder de la conaie
no cede a las concesiones del presidente
guillermo lasso
bueno pudimos conversar específicamente
con el presidente de la conae de los
días quizás ellos han dicho que luego de
acceder a la casa de la cultura
comenzarán a realizar así las reuniones
las asambleas popular y ahí a partir de
ellos que ellos emitirán unas decisiones
en el camino ha dicho el día durante la
jornada de leonidas iza ellos consideran
que no han sido respondido a todos sus
demandas han dicho que llegan aquí todo
para presentar diez puntos y no se irán
sin los diez puntos otro sector también
ha expresado preocupación de el tiempo
que ha tardado el presidente de
república en responderle lo cierto es
que continúan radicalizando y han dicho
que mantendrán así sus demandas
inclusive luego de estar en la casa de
la cultura gustado gracias por ese
informe desde quitó y cambiamos de tema
en colombia comenzó el empalme entre el
gobierno saliente de iván duque y el del
recién elegido gustavo petro el
mandatario actual recibió al que será el
primer presidente de izquierda del país
cafetero en el palacio de nariño
petro y su vicepresidenta francia
márquez recibieron las credenciales del
órgano electoral y asumirán su cargo el
próximo 7 de agosto
y hace 25 años la escritora británica
jkrowling publicó el primer libro de la
serie de harry potter el aniversario de
la piedra filosofal se cumple
puntualmente el 26 de junio pero desde
ya comenzaron los festejos por una de
las historias más leídas harry potter y
la piedra filosofal es el tercer libro
más vendido de la historia con 120
millones de copias la serie entera de
este aprendiz de mago ha vendido más de
500 millones y ha sido traducida a más
de 80 idiomas distintos
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]